野沢なち犬の巣
かみじょう素敵な綿の中にはない
日本にいるので
先日ツイッターで
質問したのですが、日本での生活について質問があれば送っ
てください。好きな質問をいくつか選んで、
ちなみにこのIIにも関連してい
ます。 約1週間前にツイッターでアンケートを投稿しました
が、外国人
は日本に来てから生活が良くなっ
たのか
という質問でした。この動画に質問した人の多くは、
そのツイートへの回答に興味があるのではないかと思います。
ちなみに70〜70
％はい日本に来て
よかったです30％いいえなのでその
ツイートを下にリンク
しますがとにかくQ＆Aに入りましょう
大丈夫なええと勉強の1年と私は試してみます d
これらの質問は通常よりも少し早く行います。これは、
通常
、1つの質問に時間がかかりすぎるため
、1年間の
学習でレベルに達することができるためですが、jlptだけ
では、話すスキルをテストしないためです。
あなたは一年中効果的に勉強しているでしょう
本当に
本当に本当にハードコアで、
あなたが
一年以内にそのレベルに到達したいのなら話すことに集中することは決してないので
、あなたの最終目標が開発することであるならおそらくそれは可能ですが私はそれをお勧めしません
バランスの取れた日本人は
、日本に住んでいるアパートに関連する請求書
と、ガスの請求書が最も高いと思われる理由を説明できますか？
私はお湯にガスを使用するだけだと誓います。
請求額を下げるためのヒントは
、一般的に請求額を下げるという点で便利ですが、
これは実際にはユーティリティの問題ではありませんが、
Softbankをまだ使用している場合は
、できるだけ早くまたはDoCoMoスイッチを使用してください。
蝸牛志摩にとっては、それは
予算提供者のようなものだと思います。
現在の州の予算提供者の中には、
とにかく私がQTモバイルと呼ばれるこのサービスを使用しているということです。
月と私
はあなたに80ドルのような同じ種類の計画を支払っていたので
、蝸牛セッションに切り替え
ますが、
それはあなたが日本に住んでいるかもしれないあなたの通常の請求額を
下げる最も簡単な方法
です 香港のギャングの
人々があなたのお金のためにあなたに嫌がらせをしようとし
ているので、私にとって
最もうまくいくと思うのは、
本当に本当に
謝罪するのではなく、
実際に私がそうするように言うように、本当にあなたの足を下に置くことです テレビを
持っていないので、双子の娘ができたらとても楽になりまし
た。彼がドアに来たとき、
私は合法的に忙しいよう
でした。 ちなみにテレビはここから出ます
私はテレビを持っていないので ええ
、それは私のアドバイスです。あなたの足を大丈夫
にしてください。2030年までにあなたの双子は10
歳になります。可能な限りバイリンガルになるように育てるつもりですか。
これは良い
質問です。
現在、私たちは主に家で英語を使い
、次に外で日本語を使います。
家の
ことで、それぞれの言語のバランスが取れると思いますが、
大学での言語学の言語学の勉強中に出会った学術文献に基づいて、大学卒業
後も
証拠は見えたようです
完全にバイリンガルの人を育てるとき、それらの言語のそれぞれは、単一言語の
人と比べて少し苦しん
でいることを示します。そのため、私は
支配的な言語を持っている方が良い
と思うので、彼らの支配的な言語だと思います
少なくともこの
時点では、日本語よりも英語を使用しているので、おそらく英語になるでしょう
が、ジョーイのように
、私が今まで出会った中で本当に話す数少ない人の1人です。
■両方の言語が流暢
に、
両方の言語が両方の言語ではなくBレベルのようになっているのではなく
、A +レベルのようになっているので
、その理由の1つが
ジョーイが本当に
賢いからだと思わない限り、わかりません。
バイリンガル環境で育ち、
最終的には両方の言語でA +レベルに到達することを誰もが期待するのが現実的である場合
、そのため、次の質問を
言えば、
少なくとも1つの主要言語または1つの
学術言語を使用するのがおそらく最善だと思います
日本で働くことで自分を燃やさないようにする方法なので、過去に日本で働くことについて
私が作ったビデオを簡単に参照
します。日本
に住むのは素晴らしいことですが、日本で働くことは
、会社によっては特に日本企業内で働くことです。
それほど素晴らしいことではありません。それは、
厳格な階層のように、
日本で成功するための私のローガンの公式は、日本
に住み、日本に住むことのすべてのメリットを享受することですが、努力して
取り組むことです。  k独立して、または
確かに自分自身に合った会社で働いていて、それ
が日本の外国企業であろうと、自分と同じ
価値を持つ日本企業で
あろうと、基本的に私
がこのビットで言いたいのは私です
今は日本に住んでいてとても幸せですが
、YouTubeをやっていたのは
、日本の大学や日本の会社のように働いていたときでした。それは
、
この仕事が私にとってはるかに優れていて、
その日本のシステムで働くのが好きではないからです。
ですから
、日本で自分のことをやってみること
は素晴らしいのですが、日本で働くことはそれほど
素晴らしいことではないので、日本で車を運転したことがあるなら、自分のこと
をして日本に住むことのメリットを享受するのが最善です。
はい、
私は車を持っていて、ほぼ毎日運転し
ています。
少なくとも米国との大きな違い
は、日本の人々
は実際にはどうやってあなたの言うことをしているのかということです。
典型的な
アメリカ人d だから、人々は怒りに耳を傾けないので
、日本では、日本で
運転するほうがはるかに楽しいです。
私の研究グループが大いに役立つキオワのスキルをどのように向上させるのですか？
しかし、私だけ
が研究に携わっています jlptと私の研究所の
その研究グループで現在勉強している3人を超えて私はこれから
自分で
それをするのは難しくなりすぎると感じ
ますこれについて
は私のパトレオンシリーズで少し話しました
が、私はしません 日本語
を勉強している他の人と一緒に勉強することを本当にお勧めします。
なぜなら、それは
本当に良い動機であり、
あなたが話す動機を与えるかもしれませんが
、あなたが聞く日本語の90％が
外国人によって話されている日本語であるとき、社会を勉強し続けることを知っているからです。
あなたの日本語にはあまり良く
ないので、私があなたに勧めたいのは
、勉強会のようにするのではなく、あなたが日本語を話す日本語のパートナーのようではなく
、あなたの興味を共有する日本人の友達を作る
ことです あなた
が日本語を話すこと、そして
時々あなたは英語に切り替えて、
そのよう
なものはすべてが
日本語であり、あなたはあなたの体重を超えてパンチすることを余儀なくされ、
私が英語を話すようにこの交換のようではありません
そして、あなたは日本語を話します。なぜなら、
あなたがそれをするとき、それは遅すぎるので
、あなたはあなたの日本語を上達させることに本当に集中
することができないようです。 私の音声シリーズで
話していることの1つ
は、日本の映画を選んで
繰り返し再生し、映画のすべての行を
覚えられるまで、1か月間毎日何度も見るのが好きなことです。
そして、日本語で話したときに不思議に思う映画が上映されているので、それを引用することができ
ます。
定期的に行わない場合は、自分で録音
することもできます。
これは今日私がやった
ことですが、第二言語の日本語でカメラの前でそれを強制された場合、
それを聞いたときはそれほど効果的ではありませ
んが、一度あなたが
試してみてくださいそれは本当にやりがいのあること
ですそしてあなたが
次に実際に外に出て日本人のように日本語を話すときにそれを数回やったら
それはそれほど威圧的ではないので
それらの神経の多くは落ち着くでしょう
オリンピックに向けて準備をしているなら、それが大いに役立つことがわかりまし
た。長期的には日本にどのような影響がある
と思いますか。これは本当に面白いと思います。
ビデオ全体のように作るのが好きかもしれません。
オリンピックの日付と同じくらい長い話短い話
は悪夢のようになると思い
ます日本中の日本人の
ように、家からオリンピック
を見ているのは、とても楽しいことだと思います。 エンジョ 日本でオリンピックを見るのは、
いわば彼らにとって誇りのようなものです
が、オリンピックが日本で開催される
と決定される前から、日本に来たがらない外国
人がたくさんいるようです。 日本中
からたくさんの人が来
て、夏になると、
日本の夏はとてつもなく暑くて
、電車はひどいです。
オリンピック自体も元気になっているような気がします。 オリンピック
に行くのに苦労しているような気がします。
スタジアムなどが好きになるのと同じ
ように、
かなりの数の人の口に悪い味がするかもしれないので
、YouTubeのように見るつもりです。
」 明らかに観光に良いでしょう
そしてその特定の年
だけでなく将来もそうですしかしええ
、日本の今年の夏はとても大変で、
毎年ますます暑く
なり、東京に行くでしょ
う 最も暑い
キルトのようにすごいのに加えて、私は行きたくないのですが
、行くことに興味があるなら
、私に止めさせないでください。
日本は米国の33パーセントを占めています。
東京のラッシュアワーの地下鉄イワシの荷造りについては誰もが
知っているスペースの約4％の人口ですが、他の県や都市の日常生活で
は、私が住んでいる場所であるベットブーツのように、田舎のように見えても混雑しているように感じますか？
美しく開いている
いいえ、それ自体はそれほど混雑しているとは感じませんが、日本の土地に
はプレミアムがあることを日常生活の中で小さな思い出のように感じます。
つまり、私が運転する
車は軽自動車と呼ばれています。 まるでそれは非常に
小さい車で、600 cc未満のエンジンを考えて
いるので
、誰もが毎日運転する多くの車は非常に
小さいので、スマートカーと同じくらい小さいです。
よく彼らはアパート
自体がとてもいいです彼らは
通常アメリカのアパートのように比べてかなり小さい
のでそれ自体は混雑しているとは感じませ
んが、土地とスペースにプレミアムがあることを思い出させるものはほとんどありません
日本
は田舎でも日常的に外国人を見かけることが多いので
、これ
も面白いので
、実は日本人に対する外国人の比率が最も高い別府に住ん
でいます。  APUと呼ばれ
、そこに行く学生の半数
は外国人であり、
そこを卒業した学生の多くは
別府に滞在する
ことになり、私がそこで教えなかったような外国人がいることを教えるたくさんの先生のように私は
外国人だったのでそこで働いていたので
、そのブースの人たちは
外国人との交流に
慣れていて、変な視線などは決してありませ
んが、離れるとすぐに
向こうの外国人のようになる
こともありますが
日本人
は外国人との交流に全く慣れていないというのは、ある種
の誤解だと思います。確かに20年か30年前のことだと思います。
ueと私は
間違いなくもっとたくさんのルックスの
ようになりました2007-2008年に日本に初めて来たのは1
年間留学しましたが、それ
は日本の若者が
留学してから戻ってくるという非常に速い法律を変えて
います 彼らは本当に
英語で話し、外国人と交流することに慣れてい
て、同時に日本に住む外国人が増えているので
、ベッドブーツ
ではまったく問題がないようですが、
日本の他の地域では
少なくなっています 大したことで
はないが、外国人
は年々珍しくなっているので
、外国人が日本に住むことで最も一般的なネガティブな生活習慣
は何ですか？
素晴らしい質問
です。
これは面白いです。これは
、私が以前働いていた古い場所の1つで働いていたときに、日本人の男性から得たアドバイスです。
確かに
Jです 物事を行うための日本語のような方法であり
、それを簡単に要約
すると、ルール内でやりたいことは何でもできます
が、そうすればすべてがスムーズに進みますが、それを
実行するとすぐに何かを実行するのは難しくありませ
ん 通常のルールから抜け出すと、
すべてがファックス機のように使用するアプリケーションの
ように作成しなければならない完全な混乱になります。これは
本当に極端な例のようですが
、それ
はあなたが外に出るとすぐに起こるようなものです。
普通の会社で普通のことの範囲
基本的に日本人の男が私に言ったこと
は、あなたがこの日本の会社で働いているとき、
何が起こるか
は、ここで働く時間が長くなるほど、
最初は本当に一生懸命に努力
するでしょう 物事は最も効果的な
方法で行われるので、それはあなた
が可能な限り最も速く最も効果的な方法で物事を成し遂げたいということです
が、日本の会社で働くとき、あなたは
しばしばたくさんの赤いテープに出くわします
最初は気になりませんが、
時間が経つにつれて何かを成し遂げるアイデアが浮かびますが、それをやり遂げる
ことは
できませんが、最初に始めたときは3、4回くらいでやり遂げられないかもしれません。
何
年も会社にいるのは
、赤いテープの
量と、アプリケーションの量と、
最初にやらなければ
ならないことだけで、そのことをやるのに大丈夫だと
彼が言ったからです。
自分の仕事の感覚を失うと、
日本人になりますね。
彼は
、それはあなたが
もう少し用心深く、あなたほど多くの間違いを犯さないことを意味するので、それが問題になること
もあると言いました。 仕事はし
ますが、それ
は非常に悪いことであり
、ズームアウトして状況を見ることができる
はずです。これはとても愚か
です。実際に愚かであり、すべての状況がそうであるとは限らないのに、なぜこのようになるのですか。
愚かですが、彼
は日本に4年間住んだ後でも言った r
5年間、その最初の
種類の好奇心を手放さないでください私は
物事を可能な限り最も効果的な方法でやりたいと思ってい
ます客観的でズームアウトし
て、日本に住んでいる時間の経過とともにどのように変化
するかを見てください
公式の書類をメールで受け取るはい
、いいえ私は
もう日本人のことを心配しません
私は自営業であるため、通常は税金に関連しているので心配
になります。
私は週に一度郵便で税金に関連する何かのようになることを心配する必要
がありますそしてそれは
これらすべての複雑な用語の
ようですそしてそれはあなたがこの莫大な金額のようにこれだけのお金を借りているようです
そして
それは私に大きな時間をストレスを与えます
過去1年間は個人
会計士、または過去1年ほどは日本の個人会計士と仕事をし
てきましたが、それは非常に役立ちました。
外国人が日本で働くために外国人で
はなく日本で
働くためにたくさんのお金を稼ぐ6人
多くの情報私が
言っているのはそれが彼が私に言ったことであり、
彼は税率がどのよう
に上がると予想されるか 日本などで
よく話を
しているの
ですが、今やっていることを続けていくのはいいのです
が、自分の会社を作って、
どうしたら税金を節約できるのでしょうか。 私は行ったことをしました、そして彼
はおそらく一年かそこらのようにそうそう言いまし
た、しかし彼らは自営業ではなく会社の従業員
である中産階級の人々のために中産階級に税金を上げるつもりな
ので実際にはそうではありません 今年
もそうすることで私を救うことができたとしても、2、3年の間にそれをするとお金を失う
ので意味がありません。それは
来年も税率が上がり、
彼らは上がると予想されているからです。 再び
その後ああこの私 とてもおもしろい
です。特に第二次世界大戦の歴史を日本人がどのように教えているかについて
どう思いますか。
日本の公立学校
が第二次世界大戦中に日本が犯した残虐行為についてもっと教えてくれればいいのです
が、
さまざまな残虐行為を犯したのは日本だけではない
と思います。 第二次世界大戦中も
米国が
ひどいことをかなりの割合で行ったことは明らかです。
その戦争は
ただの悪であり、こちら側が明らかに良かったと言うのは簡単です。
面は
明らかに悪かったのです
が、自信を持って言えるほどの教育を受けていないので、
ここでは
言いません。
日本人の先生がもっと教えてくれたら、日本人ならいいと思い
ます。 残虐行為
日本人はそうしましたが、同時に
アメリカ人が犯した残虐行為が
アメリカの学校でもっと取り上げられ
たらいいと思います。関西は
理解できたのですが、なぜ話せ
なかったのか 日本人は事務処理が大好きなようです。
それは文化的な
ことです。事務処理は一種の
物理的なものであるため、口コミで確認するだけでなく
、紙
を見て問題がないかどうかを注意深く行うことの表れです。
口頭で、そして
私がステレオタイプで話す場合、日本社会は一般的にステレオタイプで
西洋の文化のようにかなり慎重であるため、なぜ
日本人が事務処理をとても好きなの
か、または事務処理が日本でとても人気があるのかは簡単にわかります
事務処理なので、日本の米軍基地を訪問する機会があったことはありますか？
はい、実際に行ったことはありますが、ほとんどすべての基地に行ったことがあると
思います。
APUでは、APUに
行く日本人学生を募集するのが私の仕事でし
た。APUが探している学生、
またはバイリンガルの半分の学生が好きな
ので、日本人のように日本の
米軍基地内に住んでいる学生はたくさんいます。
妻アメリカ人兵士夫またはその
反対ですが、最初のものは通常
はるかに一般的であるため、私はほとんど
すべての人
に行った
ことがあります。あなたが門を通り抜けるようなもので、あなたのように文字通りアメリカです。
まるでアメリカに行っているような感じですが、
実際は日本国内のアメリカですが
、街の看板
のようにとてもスーパーアメリカンで、建物の
見た目やレストランの
ようです。
文字通り、沖縄や横須賀などの街をドライブしているようなものです。
日本の軍事基地がある場所ならどこでも、ゲートを通り抜けて突然ドライブします。
まるで
日本の小さなアメリカの小さな街にいる
かのようですが、それは野生ですが、それを行う機会があれば、
それを強く
お勧めし
ます。職場の気候を州の気候とどのように比較するかは非常に興味深い
です。
厳格な階層/複雑な
行動規範があります。もし
そうなら、その特定
の期待の構造と外国の
マナーに対する称賛はあなたにとって難しいものでした。私は
おそらくその最初
の質問とそれに続く質問の中
で答えると思います。 一般
的に日本で物事を成し遂げるには多くの時間がかかります
が、途中で犯される間違いは少ないですが、アメリカ人としての外国人として、その
価値は伝統的な日本人よりも
典型的なアメリカ人の伝統的な価値にはるかに近いです
日本の会社で働くのは難しかっ
たので、自分の価値観がよりよく調和していることを知っている人にもう一度勧め
ます
日本の価値観と比較して
、日本企業の価値観に自分自身
を押し込もうとするのでは
なく、日本で自分自身のことをするのは、どこにいても典型
的なアメリカ人または西洋人です。 誰
も私が理解できることを知らずに私を侮辱したことはありません私が日本語を
理解
できることを人々が知らなかっ
たことがあり、彼らが私について話していることを知ることができ
ましたが、通常それが起こったとき私はただ
口が悪いことは一度もなかったので、無視してください。二度と
日本語で私を侮辱
する
ことはあり
ませんでした。
日本人はい
、
文字通り日本人がいなくても日本旅行を楽しむことができますが、
日本旅行を楽しむことと日本での生活を楽しむことには大きな違いがあります。
たとえ一ヶ月以上でもここに住み
たい
と思ったら、少なくとも基本的なレベルの
日本語が必要で
、かなりの期間ここに
5年以上滞在したいのなら 日本語の流暢
さは世界にすべての違いをもたらす
ので、あなたはまだジョエルのそれを手に入れています
か？そうかもしれませんが、人々は
まだあなたに地元の宝石を教えてくれます
まるで高校のように彼
は素敵な小さな店を何でも所有していて、
それはあなたが宝石を知っているようなものですが、それ
は一種の将軍です。
本当にもうたくさん起こり
ますが、
私はニヒリズムについてたくさん冗談を
言いますが、日本人のように誰かがあなたに悪意はないと言ったときの
99.999％のようなものです 気分を害するのはばかげている
ように、本当にいい冗談になると思うので、冗談を言うのが好き
です。
日本に移住するのは
簡単な方法なので、これは良い
質問です。 これ
も過去にも変わってきていると思うので
、日本の大学のように少し前に作ったビデオQ＆Aビデオ
で少し話しましたが、
昔は引っ越したいのならいつもそうだった
です 日本に
行くには、大学の学位を取得してから
英語の先生としてここに来
て、それを3、4
年ほど続けてから、別のキャリアに移行してみてください。
しかし、
最近はますます簡単になっています。 あなたがアメリカ人の
ように日本の大学に直接行くに
は、
おそらく5から10の日本の
大学があり、米国で同様の教育を受ける
よりも少ないお金で入学して卒業することができます。
e日本の大学は
一般的
に、米国の州立大学よりもはるかに安い
ですが、基本的に
は日本の代理店のようにアプローチし、
このように私は成功したyoutuberだと言ったyoutuberまたはフリーランスの労働者であることを認める多くの人々を知っています 私は
これをやっている成功したビジネスマンです。
日本に引っ越したいの
ですが、私を後援してくれませんか。そうすると、彼らは「はい」と言って、
3か月ほどの
事務処理の後、日本に来たばかり
です。
大学の学位を取得した人の中には、これまで日本語を勉強したことがない人もい
ますが、彼らは
日本に来たいと思っていました。
大学を卒業した申し訳ない日本人の伝統的なシステムが
ジェットプログラムで日本に来て、それまでに
8年ほど過ごした後、その後切り替えます。
それは私がやっ
たことですが、あなたが強力なスキルセットを持っているなら、それをする必要はもうありません。
それをあなたの教えと組み合わせることで落ち着いて、
日本の
コメディと西洋アメリカのコメディの間に大きな顕著な違いがありますか？
これはあまりにも興味深いですええと、
私がQ＆Aの
ような別のビデオでコメディに入った私自身の理由について話しまし
た 東京のクリエイティブでやったビデオ
基本的にはライターになりたいと思って
いたのですが、私は
優れたライターであり、大学の教授
はあなたはそうではないと言っていましたが、コメディーは大丈夫な
ので、クリエイティブなことをしたいのなら
コメディーをやって、それが起こった私は
、何かに多くの時間
を費やすたびに、5〜6年の
ように創造的な執筆に取り組んだので、同じことが
何度も起こりました。
良いけど
、あなたがやったこの他のことはかなり
面白いコメディなので、それが十分な回数起こった後、
私はちょうどコメディをやるだけだと
言った
非常に一般的に
言えば、基本的な考え方は、日本企業のように、
ドタバタコメディがはるかに多く、物理的で
視覚的であるのに対し、アメリカのコメディ
は、少し
繊細で、このようになっていると思います。
多くの自己非難的なユーモアや
そのようなもののようですが、それは
非常に一般的に言えば、私が好きなことを
見ていたように、
テレビを笑うことはできません彼女
は私の妻の場所で特別な新年のようです
新年とそのショーの大部分
は、
彼らが笑っている場合は彼らが打たれるような物理的なコメディですショーの人々が笑う場合は彼らはコウモリ
に打たれます
そしてそれは彼ら
が笑わないようにしようとしているので面白いですそして彼らは 笑って、
ハハハハハハハハハハハハハハハハハハハハハハハハハハハハハハハハハハハハハハハハハハハハハハハハハハハハハハハハハハハハハハハハハハハハハハハハハハハハハハハハハハハハハハハハハハハハハハハハハハハハハハハハハハハハハハハハハハハハハハハハハハハハハハハハハハハハハハハハハハハハハハハハハハハハハハハハハハハハハハハハハハハハハハハハハハハハハハハハハハハハハハハハハハハハハハハハハハハハハハハハハハハハハッ
2人の女の子がバスに乗って来て
、吉本
エージェンシー
のように面白がってこの曲を歌っ
ているようなものでした。 これは
子供の頃のような、または子供の歌のフォーマットの
ようなもので、ドタバタコメディのようなものとは正反対の
ようなものなので
、一般的なドタバタコメディの表面から見ると
、日本ではるかに人気がありますが
、 日本のコメディのより小さな、よりニュアンスのある
要素も
たくさんあります。それら
を探すと、将来の引っ越しを考えて日本に引っ越すことを最初に決めたときに、どのようにして住宅を定住させる場所を見つけたのかがわかり
ます。これは本当にすべてに依存します ジェットプログラムで
日本に来た場合
、彼らは
通常あなたのためにそれを世話しますが、そうでない
場合、彼らはそうしません、そして時々あなたがしなければならないことは
一緒に滞在する場所のようになることです
あなたまで友達 アパートを探すか
、ゲストハウスのように行く
必要はありませんが、日本のアパートで買い物
をしている間、1週間ほどゲストハウスのように行くことができます。
普段
はアパートで買い物をしている間、その場所に泊まれる友達がいるのが
一番いいです。
イスラム教徒の学生として日本に住むのは難しいと思いますか。
私はイスラム教徒ではないので、言うのは
難しいです。
APUにはイスラム教徒の学生が非常に多く、
ハラルフードなどもあり
ます。日本で勉強することに興味
があるなら、おそらく
イスラム教徒の学生にとって最も居心地の良い場所であり、
いくらのお金を持参する必要がありますか。
仕分け後に引っ越した場合はセットアップ費用がかかります
英語の教育会社で仕事を仕分けした後に転居した
場合たくさんの節約
があれば$10,000は素晴らしい
でしょうすべての節約がなければあなたも大丈夫です
あなたが質素で賢くて
私が10,000ドルと言う理由は
、日本には3つか4つのものが
あり、年収
が2000ドルや3000ドルの場合、それぞれが1,000ドル以上かかるからです。
あなたが日本に引っ越すまでは知らないので
、私の前に来たアルトからこの古い軽自動車を買ったように
、彼
がいたので持っていたくなかったこの古いひどい車が好きだったので、文字通り200ドルで彼からそれを買いました
日本を離れて、彼は
私からそれを持って行っ
てくれたようでした。200ドルであなたにあげます。私は大丈夫だった
ので、それを購入しまし
た。  1か月ほど経ったら
、ショットガンに1,200ドルを払わなければなりませんでした。これ
は、車の検査が義務付けられている
車の検査の
ようなものです。また、市や県の技術税
のように、多くの
人が持ち出されない住居税もあります。 彼らの
給料はこのように私に起こったし
、それは私にも起こった
あなたのようないとこ私は日本でかなりうまくやっていて
、私はついに
お金を稼ぎ始めました、そして私はいくらかの
お金を貯めました、そしてあなたはあなたが2つ
のように都市を借りているようなメールで小切手を受け取ります
市税
と市税で千ドルとあなたは好きですが
、それは所得税
と健康保険の
上にあり、
あなたが計画していなくてもあなたが支払わなければならない退職金の上にあるからです
あなたが適切な日本の会社で働いている
か、あなたの住居が
日本にある限り、日本で引退することを再確認する必要があるかもしれませんが、
私が日本で働いたことがあるときはいつでも
私もお金を払わなければなりませんでした
日本
政府の引退基金の引退に、私
が言いたいのは、
日本に来るまでは知らないかもしれない
たくさんの費用があり、それらの多くは一度に1,000ドルまたは2,000ドルかかる可能性が
あるということです だから、最初からお金を節約しておくのは良いことです
日本人として生まれ変わるのが好きですかいいえ今の私は幸せです
が
、日本のアメリカ人ジャズの外国人として税金がますます複雑になっているので
、アメリカの国籍を取り除くことを真剣に検討し始めています
アメリカの税金は非常に複雑なので、アメリカ
は世界で唯一の先進国の1つであり、
海外に住む市民に税金の報告を求め
、時には税金に加えて税金を支払う必要があると
考えています。 すでに
日本政府に支払わ
れているの
ですが、それはあなたが自営業者であるときにそれをとても大きな頭痛の種と考えるのはとても大変な
ので、私
は私のアメリカ市民権を取り除くことを考えて
います、そして唯一の
理由は税金のためです 好きなroc-rocの曲
オデッセイやj-popの曲やアーティストは好きじゃない
東京GaN昔
は、彼らが集まってきた私のお気に入りのバンドの1つだっ
たので、それはすべての人にとって素晴らしいニュースです
。  XI 19ゴールドマンと東京ゲンの
ファンなので、2020年に一緒に戻ってきます。
彼らが出したものに興奮してい
ます。3回ライブを見た
ことがあります。2回
コンサートに行って、ライブ放送のように決勝に進みました。
映画館で
も、彼ら
が解散したときはかなりクールでした。日本での最初の仕事をどのように見つけましたか。
共同
栽培をしましたか。新卒者として就職活動をしました
。 日本での就職活動は
、政府を通じて英語を教えるジェット
プログラム
でしたが、海外で始めたときは、
実際に東京のヘッドハンティング会社で働いていました。
イーストウェストコンサルティングと呼ば
れていました。 その仕事を得るために、私は履歴書の
ように書いた通常の就職活動を行ったのですが、その
一部は確かに日本語だった
と思います確かに
少なくとも一部は日本語だった
と思います ムー ltipleのインタビュー
1つは日本人もいましたが、
英語のインタビューがあり、2つ目
は日本語の部分が含まれ
ていました。それ
から、インタビューの一環として日本企業に冷たい電話をかけるの
も好きでした。それは
とてもストレスの多いものでした。 その仕事が嫌いだったのと同じくらい
、それは
私にとって長期的には
より良い経験だったと思います。 簡単
だった側で英語を教えるよう
にやっていて、それ
ができたらもう少しお金を稼いだかもしれませ
んが、
スーツを着て電車に乗るような日本のことをするようなものだったので
、
日本の会社に行く混雑したトレーニングで、
日本語で会社に電話
するのが好きで
、私は日本語を上達させ
、日本の労働
精神をよりよく理解することを余儀なくされまし
た。
その会社で働くのをやめてから数年後まで
、日本についての本当の質問をここで学んだことに気づかなかったのですが、なぜ
友達を失うのは、彼女の代わりにヨットオイルを使うの
です
か？ 今年
日本に来るので、日本人が外国人の友達を作るのに
どれだけオープンなのかと思っていたのかもしれません
が、これ
も難しい質問です。
多くの日本人が愛する日本人に完全に依存しているから
です。 外国人の友達がいて、外国人の友達
が欲しいと
思っている人もいます。ギミックのようなものです。外国人
のように本当に
興味を持っている人
もいます。友達が欲しいだけで、
たまたま外国人です。
あなたが話している相手について
は、日本人の友達はあまりいないので、
個人的
には家族の仕事に集中したいのですが、
飲酒はおそらく最良の方法です。
日本で友達を作るので
、同僚のように外に出て飲み物を飲むと、一緒に
仕事をして滞在しただけではわからなかったさまざまなことがわかります。
彼らと一緒に、正式なオフィスで彼らと話をしただけ
で、日本での生活に適応することについてあなたにとって最も難しい部分は、NHKマンについて私が答え
た最初または2番目の質問の1つに戻ります。
何年にもわたって非常に長い間
、日本に足を踏み入れるのが怖かったのは
、一般的に
日本人はあまり戦闘的ではないので、大人の
文化や日本の文化は
避けるのが最善だと言っているからです。
悪い状況を避けて
、他の人に迷惑をかけないように戦う
ので
、多くの人に長い間利用させないようにしたいと思い
ました
が、多くの人に 私は
他の人に任せました e
はそのために非常に長い間私のために決断を下し、
ここに8年か9年住んで
いた後、主にここに子供ができた後
、私は自由な時間が
すべてなくなってしまいました。
たとえば、先日銀行に行って、このフォームに
記入する必要があると言われたので
、私は
私がこれをしているときに娘の一人
を抱きしめて、娘を抱きながらこの長いフォームに記入した後
、彼女はあなたが私の腕から抜け出そうとしていることを知っている
ようでした、そしてそれは重く
て私は けいれんを与えて、
書き終えたらすぐに書くの
は大丈夫だったので、今は
フォーム全体を
コピーとして書き直す必要があります。以前
は、本当に欲しくないよう
でした。 それをすることは大丈夫ですが
その状況では私はただノーと言いました私はドイではありません
時間がないので
、これを写真に撮るだけです。それが
私がやろうとしていることです。彼ら
は大丈夫のような
ものでした。そのようなことは
最近ますます起こっているか、それは
特定のことをする時間やエネルギーがないのと同じように、私は
もっと多くの状況でノーと言います、そしてそれは私
が言いたいほどでは
なく、私は私の上を歩く人々にうんざりし
ています それは、必然的にノーと言わ
なければならないことではありませんが、より多くの状況で、あなたがそうするとき、
人々は実際には大丈夫のようになり
、彼らはあなたに代替オプションを与えるかもしれない
ので、
それはあなたが
日本で苦労しているの
かもしれませんが、調整が多すぎ
て、調整のむち打ちのようになっているかもしれ
ません。これの別の良い例は
、先日銀行に行った
別のインスタンスです。実際に銀行に行っ
て私を取得しました。
彼らがセンディだったようにストリーミングサイトをけいれんからチェックのようになっていた
毎月のように私の最初の毎月の収入のように私の毎月の
収入は100ドルのようでしたが、それは州から
の国際送金として送金として入ってきました、
そしてそれ
が日本で起こるときあなたはそれがかなり
複雑である必要があります私がしようとしていることです
と言って、彼らは
それについて少し疑っていました、そして彼らは私に電話をしました、そして彼ら
はこの転送が入ったように言った
あなたはこれが何であるか知っていますか
さて、あなたは入って、これがあなたから来ているという会社の
ようにあなたの外国の在留カードのように持ってくる必要があるという証拠を示す必要があります
そして私はそれが何であったか思い出せない何かがありましたそして私は大丈夫だと言いました
電話
で受け取ったメールを証拠として
大丈夫だと言ったので、大丈夫だと
言ったので、銀行に行って大丈夫だと言ったので、
ここにメール
があります。 かつて私がそこ
にいて、彼らがアルを持っていたとしても eady
は、メールは大丈夫だと
言っていました。これは大丈夫ではないと言っていました。
これを物理的にコピー
して銀行に戻す必要がありました。時間がなかったので
、私はそれをしていません。
このメールのコピーをお送りします。
この銀行内で印刷できます
ので、名刺に記載されているメールを送ってください。
コンビニエンスストアのように行く必要があると言われました。 それは道の向こう側にあり、
これをしている間、私は娘の1つ
を持っていますが、15分ほどで家に持ち帰って餌をやらなければならないので、時間がありません。
いいえ、それは
できません。また、同じ
ことをしました。足を下ろし
て、電話
で「これは大丈夫だと言ったのですが、これはし
ません。 これをあなたに電子メールで送るために
、あなたはすぐそこにあるそのプリンターでそれを印刷することができます、
そして彼らは銀行
の他の従業員の何人かを見て
そしてそれから好きです e
向こうの机の後ろにいた上司のような男で、
15秒間話し合った後
は、
大丈夫だったので、やむを得ずあなたが
何かを
成し遂げることができず、しばしばあなたはノーと言うことができ、影響なしに言う必要があります
が、再び
迷惑にならないでください誰も好きではないジャークになるために何かをしないでください
アニメほとんどの
アニメは素晴らしいですあなたはあなたの子供
にあなたの文化のいくつかを継承してもらいたいですか
アメリカ/西洋そしてもしそうなら
あなたがそれをしようとしている方法は
一般的
に西洋にはもっと創造性があり、すでにもっと完璧
なものがあると思います
欧米や日本国内の他の地域で作成された
もので、非常
に長い間、その特定のモデル
は日本にとって非常にうまく機能したと思います
。日本の求職システムと
日本の教育システムは また、
主に日本社会の一般的な特徴に基づいてい
ますが
、日本が伝統的に支配的だった多くの分野で中国が日本を追い抜いていると思うので、それが
車の製造や携帯電話のようなものかどうかはわかりません。
Huaweiやjemmye、そしてかつて人々だったこれらの
ような企業はすべて、
東芝ソニーのように日本に目を向けるでしょう
、そしてそのようなもの
は今中国から出てきているかなりの量の革新
があるので、日本は
中国、そして世界
の他の国々から、これ
に対抗するために日本が変化する必要
のある程度は、日本ではかなり大きいので、
私が言おうとしているのは十分な速さではありません。
日本の多くの大学が今英語でプログラムを教えているのは大丈夫だという事実は、日本がよりグローバルになりたいが日本で英語を教えているように
、これを反映していると思います
赤ちゃんの一歩のようなものであると同時に
、他のすべての国と同じように、特に中国
は毎年このような大きな飛躍を遂げて
おり、AIなどへの投資に数十億ドルも費やしてい
ます。 今やって
いることは、本当に物事を揺るがし
、教育や仕事探しなどの面でゼロから創造性にもっと重点を置くこと
です。その方法の1つは、
おそらく日本がそれを行うことができる小さな方法かもしれません。
移民が日本に来やすいよう
にすることですが、日本に
来る移民はあまり多くないので、それ自体は非常に複雑なテーマです。
そこにも摩擦がありますが、
基本的に私が
このビットで言いたいのは、日本は
両方
の観点から必要なほど創造性を重視していないと思うということです。
労働力の観点からの高等教育の教育
と私は、子供たちが今後10年または20年にわたってその変化を利用
するのに十分な速さで変化することを期待していません。その
ため、私
は親切にしたいと思います。 私自身の価値観を授け、
彼らが成長するにつれて創造性の重要性を好むのは、彼らが
日本の学校や
社会全体でそれを見るとは
思わないから
です。 私が取り出さなければならなかったいくつかのカットは、私が行っ
たいくつかの種類の
接線がありました
私は少し長すぎるスリットを持っていたと思います私は
それらのビットを切り取りました
もう1つ質問
がありますが、ここでは表示されていませんが、
よく質問している人がたくさん
います。 過去に
外国のカードをプレイしたことがあります
外国人カードに関して私が言いたかったことは
、外国人
は自分の
好きではないものを自分のがらくたに我慢しなければならず、
日本人も
自分の嫌いなものやがらくたを我慢しなければなら
ない でも、外国人の多くは
、日本人も色んなことに苦労していることに気づい
ていないように感じます。日本社会には嫌いな
ものがたくさんあります。
これらの人々が
勤勉で不平を言っておらず
、彼らは
一生懸命働いている間、外国人カードはここにいる多くの外国人にとって見栄えが良くありませ
んが、私は2つの種類を見ていると言いたいです
保守的な日本のグループが本当に好きで、
日本が
もっとグローバルになり、Twitterで
本当に戦うようなグループのようなこれらすべての問題を解決するために日本を変える必要
があるので、ほとんどが外国人です
が、日本人のメンバーがいます
両側として さて、
重要なのは、
これらのグループが
、誰もが常にお互いの
喉の奥にいて、誰
も会話をしたくないという現在の米国でのレベルにまでエスカレートしないことが重要だと私は信じています。 ですから、今の私の
最大の関心事は、日本に住む外国人としての日本での品位のようなもの
だと思います。
先日この調査を行ったとき
、70％の人が言ったからではなく、本当に嬉しかったです。
日本に住んで良かったのですが、日本に来て不満
だと言った人でさえ、喧嘩
はなかったので
、日本に住むことの長所と短所について300件のコメントがあり
、すべてが市民的でした。 日本の文化のこの部分のように表現し
ていることを知っているこれらすべての人々のように、これは素晴らしいことでした。
私は好きではなかったので、これは
後ろ向きに感じましたが、それは大丈夫です。
このようなこと
が今後も続き
、ますます政治的に
なり、この時点で暴言になりつつあるので
、ここでビデオを終了します。明け
ましておめでとうございます。
みんなで2020年を楽しみましょう。  ：
それらをロードすると、国民を浪費しません